participants and clicking on the blue
rays hand icon at the bottom right of
the screen
your rate your raised hand icon will
only be lowered when you have spoken
you will be invited to speak in the
order in which hands are raised
please unmute the when i invite you to
speak
and neuter again when you finish
speaking please note that this meeting
will be live stream to the council's
youtube channel this evening
please be mindful therefore that members
of the public following the meeting via
the live stream
will be able to see each of us on screen
individually
please announce yourself by name when
speaking and if you want to refer to
anything in the offices report
can you please first clearly state the
relevant page number
and the paragraph number and as i said
it's in the last week and i will try my
very best to take um your points
in order um if i do slightly get it
wrong i apologize in advance but i will
get around to all of you and allowing
all of you to speak
i can see that sony looks like we're
live is it
very best to take your points
in order um
okay
there seems to be quite a delay there
sonia yeah so we're
we're ready
okay
right okay um good evening members
welcome to the review committee meeting
this evening
i'll start by the gender item number one
which is apologies
for absence we have received apologies
from
councillor mister and councillor mrs
shaw
and councillor mrs hoy
agenda item number two which is
substitute members we have
councillor merrick on behalf of
councillor mrs
shaw councillor dre on behalf of
councillor mr shaw
and councillor mr hoy on behalf of
councillor mrs hoy
up to number three which is non-members
attending
um i don't believe there are any
there are um i'm just checking
it's a little bit slow at mine but we've
got councillors
fd and councillor williams
so i'm just trying to scroll through the
names on the right hand side to
apologize just to try and find yes
that's right council fd
and councillor williams welcome this
evening
i had to number four which is to receive
minutes of the meeting held on the 7th
of july
if members are in agreement please be
designed i will sign them as soon as
they are
available for me to do so
our members happy agreed
agreed yeah great job okay
lovely thank you very much
back to number five to receive
declarations of interest including any
whipping declarations
if you have you can just raise your hand
right
i'll take that as none
so moving on to item number
six which is kovid 19 initial lessons
learned members hopefully have had a
chance to review the report that's been
circulated
and for this report this evening we
welcome angela hutchins
and angela law as well i believe for
this item
is that correct so the chair um i'll be
speaking to this report
okay lovely um angela if i could if i
could ask you to start although members
have had a chance to
um read the report if you could just
talk members through
and just highlight any particular parts
of the report that you would like to
to raise um the awareness of two members
and then answer any questions that
that may follow is that okay yes that's
absolutely fine happy too
lovely thank you very much thank you
members
um the a report on
uh kovic 19 and the lessons learned by
the council in managing
uh the global pandemic in the district
was originally scheduled to be
on your agenda for january 21
and of course it's a matter of this
committee to decide whether it wants to
look at
the situation again at that juncture but
with the permission of the chair
um i bring this report to you earlier
than that date with
our initial findings to reflect the fact
that we are trying to incorporate
a a process of continual review and
learning
as we move through this pandemic unlike
many emergency
procedures where we would normally move
into
contingency planning over a very short
period of time
what's become very clear is that
pandemic planning is going to
see us working in a new way for at least
the next
12 to 18 months so it seemed pertinent
to bring a report at this juncture
to review this report was based on
feedback from officers and from members
experiences of the leadership team of
the council and myself in particular
as a gold command representative for the
council at the essex resilience forum's
strategic coordinating group for the
pandemic
the the council achieved many things
throughout the early days of the
pandemic first of all in terms of
communication setting up
new communication lines for members
staff
and for the public and creating
specialized uh
and targeted communications for those
particular audiences
decanting an entire office um both from
south street and the civic suite in
rayleigh
into an agile working environment
whilst continuing to deliver business as
usual and
the additional work required of us by
government
the financial impact of covet is
something we're still working through
members will have seen
uh the report from the section 151
officer for the july return
to central government regarding uh the
pressures which the council
is experiencing because of of covid with
an allocation from government towards
that
cost of just over one million pounds but
pressures in excess of one and a half
million pounds
we're going to need to keep an eye on
that um as
as time progresses and to keep our
financial losses under
review the government scheme for
income loss mitigation was published uh
just last week
and that covers members irrevocable
sorry irrevocable irrecoverable and
unavoidable losses from fees and charges
uh essentially the council absorbs the
first five percent
of planned income loss and government
compensates 75 p
in the pound for every pound thereafter
um so the 151 officer is working through
that guidance currently
and further updates will be provided to
members and indeed
will be an integral part of the budget
planning process that's due to begin
uh in a little over four weeks time
the lessons learned are set out in the
report and captured uh
in the next steps that we're planning to
take forward in paragraph six
broadly the council responded extremely
well to this unprecedented
situation and it's worth remembering
that in comparison to our neighbouring
authorities
um such as baseline south end the
council is very much smaller and yet we
managed to punch above our weight
and with an impressive list of
achievements set out in paragraph 3.7 of
the report
the council and its partners stepped up
they worked together
they worked well under around a unifying
challenge
equal partnerships were created with
members of the voluntary community
sector and other community partners
data sharing moved relatively easily
between
agencies and improved significantly as
parts of gdpr were suspended
and the focus on place and
community-based interventions really
brought to the fore
the strength and resilience of our
community groups and our
our residents of course we can always do
better
and we should always strive to do better
but uh and the feedback
that has been received as part of this
process has been incorporated into the
workplace restoration planning
as referenced in the report our own
local outbreak response plan
the connect program the asset
development programme
corporate risk management my ongoing
attendance at the essex resilience forum
and real-time learning and emergency
plan
preparation but in conclusion sharon i'm
extremely proud of the council's
response
to the global pandemic and the
resilience commitment
and goodwill of the officers who did
their very best under these extremely
trying circumstances
and chairman if you have any questions i
should be happy to answer them
thank you very much um
a few members have indicated to speak um
a lot i will come to you in just one
second
um i think just on on behalf of the as
chairman of the review committee um i
think it is important
to say that this report as um as angela
did touch on
is really kind of just giving members a
an idea and a taste of what exactly has
happened so far
um i have breakthrough report and i've
got some questions i think my initial
thoughts were
it almost seems to have come a little
bit too
early um not that's a bad thing or
criticism because i think it's right
that we did
produce a report at this moment in time
um but obviously as things
continue to move so so quickly i mean i
think this report was probably
finished a good couple of weeks ago
which it had to be
and things have developed so much more
just in the last
two weeks so i do think members just
need to bear in mind obviously
angelo is here to answer questions um
but just bear in mind that
um this report i i would like to think
is probably going to be the first of
maybe a couple or a few that we are
going to see coming forward
um and i think we just need to bear that
in mind for the moment so
i think on that note i'll go straight
over to um councillor wilkinson who was
the first to indicate to speak
is that okay council wilkinson sorry
thank you chairman i was just um
i'm muting myself thank you chairman um
i i actually think that um before i
start i'd like to
recognize the the extra demand that was
placed on the council offices as well
and and there was no mean feat um to
to achieve uh business as usual and all
the extra demands and i pl
and i do have a couple of questions and
a couple of um
comments to make about the report but i
don't want that to be lost the fact that
i do recognize that and i do think it's
important to make that point clear
um and you know and i was involved in a
lot of the things that were going on as
well
my my first thought is
when i read this um was about whether
it's
um it incorporates all of the the facts
and it's there there are some negative
aspects and we have to recognize a
report
for us moving forward has to be um
critically
positive as well as negative so we
recognize to learn that the learning
from that
the way i've read this report and it may
be me and i accept it maybe me chairman
but the way i've read this report is
that
the the officer section of it is all
positive and the only negative side of
it has come from the members
comments at the end and and and i said
the question why really because
there are there are a couple of things
which i picked out which i would just
like to mention and i think that it's
worthy of mentioning because i don't
think
i don't think the report is fair
entirely because of this
and i'm going to make reference to
paragraph 3.4 to start off with there's
only two i'm going to pick out the first
is paragraph 3.4
where it talks about at the beginning 95
percent of employees were equipped with
a technology to ensure they could work
remotely now
the reason i picked that out chairman is
because
um you or any other member here may or
may not be aware
and i know the group leaders here will
be aware because we were having these
conversations on the group leaders calls
two or three times a week
with the then leader councillor steptoe
and
uh sean stratton around um
various aspects of the the ability or
rather the inability of officers to be
able to do something simple like
printing now the reason that came up was
because
um i discovered in the early stages of
the lockdown and i'm talking right at
the time
where everybody was banged up in their
own homes when allowed out
that the council reverted from its its
agreed
standard policy of public consultation
around development and planning
but rather than sending letters out to
everybody they were posting notices
outside
the the the premises this happened in my
ward
which is why i was made aware of it at
the very time when people weren't
allowed out
is the time we as a council chose just
to simply put a notice outside houses
and i raised this at the time with sean
stratton
um to be told a couple of things first
of all um it was a nicety apparently
was his radiology but the other thing
was that we were told that they didn't
have the ability to
print that's why they weren't being done
so um as much as i
recognize in here the fact that as
angela has said
moving staff to an agile working
environment is a difficult concept and i
do recognize that there has to be some
recognition
that we cannot say that they were
equipped that 95 percent
were quick to do so without recognition
also the failings because we
we did fail when it came to our public
consultation around development and it
was something i raised
in the group leaders calls at the time
um so i i don't think that section of
the report
is fair um and i have no issues with
it with failings at all because we learn
but i do think the report needs to be
representative of that
the the second and final thing i'd like
to raise chairman if i don't if i may is
paragraph 5.8
um and i'm going to i'm going to
paraphrase this really
because the it's there
this is where members have recognized
the lack of
emergency planning um and i mean i
personally have spoken to a number of
other members uh some of whom are senior
members of the administration
and the it has been generally accepted
that emergency planning for ruptured
council price this pandemic was
woefully shocking and pretty much
non-existent
now i do understand that that's
something that may be improved moving
forward and i would
um and i would i hope that would be the
case
but again chairman there's no reference
to that in this report
um and so i find it difficult to support
this as a report going forward
i don't think it's particularly
representative of where
we are right now or where we have been
in the months during the lockdown if
that makes sense
um and and i'd just like to make those
two points and i think that you know
and i recognize the fact that it's been
a very very difficult time and
i don't wish to be critical i really
don't but i do think that any report
that we make for it to be beneficial for
us to move forward it has to be honest
and i don't feel that it's entirely
honest and that's all i wish to say the
matter
thank you okay
uh thank you council wilkinson um andrew
would you like to come back to
cancer wilkinson on one or both of those
points yes thank you chair
um first of all um i have to object
council
wilkinson to the fact or to any
assertion that this report is not honest
um because i fundamentally refute that
um i take your point around the point
that the points you made around
mitigation the 95 relates to those
numbers of users who in migra had been
migrated to the azure platform and so
therefore were capable of working
agilely
we've always accepted that there are
elements of the
um uh council services that have not
fully
been able to move into the um agile
environment and that is reflected
in the comments within the report when
it talks about those
members of staff who are still working
on site and it also talks about paper
processes and
manual handling which has not been able
to transfer into an agile environment
those
those comments do exist in relation to
the specific point you make about
printing
that was dealt with at the time you are
quite right and you had you did make
those representations
um i had not included that specific
point in
the uh in the report um
not because i don't acknowledge that it
was a point not made but that
simply it was uh it was
not something that came into the uh
overall
uh drafting but i'm happy to take that
away as
as feedback in relation to
role of the of emergency planning i
think
i do accept in the report and officers
particularly accepted
um the uh adequacy of emergency planning
is something that needs to be has been
considered and needs to continue to be
considered
as i mentioned at the beginning of this
report
um emergency planning is usually and
almost
exclusively short-term contingency
planning in the face of a
short-lived emergency so whether that's
flood fire or famine
um it is intended to be a short-lived
thing and
usually uh amounts in in business
continuity terms amounts to an i.t
outage
so it's a matter of days if you know
potentially weeks
not months or even years so i would
question
that anybody's business continuity plans
would and emergency planning scenario
um for any district authority or indeed
any organization
in the uk was fully could say that they
were fully prepared for a global
pandemic
and of course therefore we have to as
i've mentioned
um learn as we go and that's why i would
agree chair that this is the first
report of a number of reports i'd expect
to bring
back to review as a process of continual
learning and continual feedback
so although i take the feedback that
the concerns were raised about emergency
planning those concerns are fully
reflected in the report they are shared
both by officers and members alike
but i would not accept that they are
woefully inadequate full stop
in the context of a global pandemic
plans for business continuity for
short-term yt outages
clearly need to be strengthened and one
of the first things that we've done as
part of this
initial lessons learned is to strengthen
our response to that
um and that's why we have a local
outbreak response plan
which pulls together all the learning so
that if we end
a second spike or a uh a a second
outbreak
that we are better prepared next time
around
thank you angela um obviously just a
reminder to
to everybody i think obviously the the
role of the review committee
is to act as a critical friend i think
councillor wilkinson was quite right in
saying that
um the criticism i think is is is
genuinely meant
um to help and for everybody to learn
officers and members alike
um any criticisms really and the idea of
this report as well
is not to blame anybody um you know the
circumstances behind that
behind the pandemic it was nothing
like any of us have experienced before
and it was always going to be difficult
to
meet everybody's expectations 100
percent and
council wilkinson did you want to come
back i didn't know if you wanted to come
back on that point
i saw you unmuted i did actually you've
taken the words out of my mouth
i couldn't put it better myself and
thank you for saying that that is
precisely where i was coming from
and i did go to great lengths at the
start of me speaking to say that i'm
i'm trying not to be critical because i
do recognize the good work that was done
and i i just feel as though um the
report
if it's a report of how the council did
um i don't think it's an entirely
fair reflection that's all i'm saying
because i think there are aspects that
could have been done better
um and that's not a criticism it's an
observation um i didn't read it in the
report that's all i'm saying i couldn't
find it and i've read it and read it a
couple of times
and i couldn't find the the the bits
that said that and
um and that's it and i'm i don't wish
anymore thank you
okay thank you council wilkinson um i
mean i will take some more questions in
a minute i know that some members i
think i read the report and
the notes that i've made are um to
to will be to note this report but also
to guide because i think
at the outset i can imagine this was
probably quite um
quite a job to to angela to get this
from
nothing to just to where we are at the
moment because of how this is moving on
um and i think council because it does
make a point i think there probably
are some experiences that we've all
experienced that
haven't been mentioned in this report
but that may be because
there are either too many of them or we
consider them to be smaller
issues that make up a larger picture and
i think it's important
i would like to as a committee for us to
be perhaps guiding angela
with regards to further reports as to
exactly what
we are expecting to see in future
reports just
just to provide some assistance um
i hope that that's just my thoughts
anyway um councillor mrs mason
uh thank you chair um
i think the comments made about a
critical friend and more than
appropriate
and i think the difficulty that we
sometimes have is quite naturally when
criticism is leveled it's taken as a
negative
and it's invariably meant destructively
and
indeed this committee's major role
is to be a critical friend
returning to the report i'm saying i'm
going to be a critical friend
the communications and the source of
information
in the regular group leader meetings
council newport has regularly requested
for the
engagement of those daily briefing notes
um opened and read rather than just the
impressions of the total number of times
sent out now despite these
repeated requests and we're talking
about the best part of five months now
this information has still not been
provided
nor to my knowledge collected perhaps
the officer can report back as when
this will be done because i think that's
something that is
very important there is no point in us
sending out
uh misses and information however well
written
and how important it is if it's not
being
opened and read and that's what we need
to know
so that's the point i'd like to come the
office to come back to
at perhaps the next review meeting
the receptions another point here were
understandably shut
and unfortunately the telephone system
was at best farcical
despite many reports incidents examples
and conversations at the group leaders
meetings and elsewhere
this has still not been resolved whilst
i understand some work has been
undertaken the frustrations the distress
and the confusion for residents
attempting to telephone at this
difficult time
cannot be understated and the remedy for
this needs to be undertaken as a matter
of urgency
again i would like to see regular
updates reported to this committee
until this is resolved the situation and
the problems
continue the
relocation of officers was to be
applauded
and i believe helped by the fact that
many officers already worked
partly from home i agree with councillor
wilkinson that our officers
should be applauded and we should
acknowledge
the work that they have done in these
difficult times and the continued
service delivery was exemplary
bearing in mind the difficult and
stressful times that we all
endured i do hope that this will be
recognized appropriately in the future
is the authority taking advantage and
this is a question for the future and i
i would like to really reinforce that
how well our officers did do with the um
continued service delivery i think we
have done exceptionally well as a
council and it's good to
note positive things is the authority
taking advantage of
the situation of officers working from
home
to examine future working patterns
and that's something i'm hoping that
will be done and again i would like to
see reported back i don't expect
a detailed answer now
however i do have a small issue with the
accuracy of this football is not all
members were provided with equipment in
a timely fashion
despite requests in fact i know that one
member couldn't attend meetings he
hadn't got equipment so there
were problems um and the other issue is
it
assumed that members were technically
able to operate such equipment
without any training that they could
alter their methods of working without
problems
no one else was or had been made
or has been made to those members with
difficulties in this respect
although this was unavoidable at the
start
in the five months since the situation
remains the same
consideration should have allowed for
greater flexibility and assistance when
requested and needed
i'm not sure that this one-size-fits-all
complies with the
equality and diversity legislation
and a question again and another
question here
um i applaud the fact that we
housed homeless rough sleepers
are we still attempting to do so like
that question
answered again not necessarily tonight
i'm hoping that we
will be doing so especially as there's a
possibility of a spike
there was no mention of the emergency
service officers
in the report or the involvement which
angela has
clarified but it does need to be
addressed in the future
express especially as concerns over the
emergency planning have been expressed
at this committee
for some years so there is some concern
there that
we need to go back on but again not
necessarily tonight
and on a much more positive note the hub
served a very important lifeline to some
residents but it delay
was whilst understandably regrettable
and
this is no criticism of our officers
the group leaders will know the other
group leaders will know but members
might not
that the majority of delay was caused by
the confusion
from central governments and from
the ever-changing messages however
if rdc is more proactive
i wonder what steps have been taken to
ensure that rdc
can be more proactive in the future
rather reliant than relying on
someone else's instructions but having
said that
although it served not very many people
but it was still a very necessary and a
very
um important part of our response to the
pandemic
and so as i say i agree that we do need
ongoing with the chair that we need on
government courts
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor mrs mason
um angela just uh touching on what um
counselor mrs mason
has asked there in particular with
regards to
um information regarding the
communications that was sent
out as to how many
people were actually opening the
communications i think
the council mrs mason was referring to
the chair um
leader of the council's statement would
that be right council mr mason
now i was i'm referring to all the
information that we sent out
as a council the briefings are mostly
from there but
basically when something's sent out
you've got a record of something sent
out that's called an impression
basically you send it out you don't know
how many people are reading that you can
very easily tell
how many people are opening that email
you can also tell and don't ask me how
because i'm not technical
but you can also tell apparently
relatively easily
how many people have read that email and
perhaps clicked on links
and that's the information that we
should be getting so that we know that
our communications
are appropriate or read and if they're
not if they're ignored
then perhaps we need to put them in a
different format or
revisit it so that is critical
information
and i do think we need to know when that
information is going to be
provided okay thank you councilman mrs
mason
um andrew did you want to come back or
can you come back are you able to come
back any questions that
um counselor mrs mason raised there i
mean
she did indicate that she was happy and
as the committee would be happy to
to receive some of those answers at a
slightly later date
um if you're not able to answer this
evening if you can that would be good
um chair i will always follow up with
some
more detailed information but um i can
answer these questions
now in terms of communication council
mrs mason has made reference to emails
and
uh email receipts um the member briefing
note was emailed to
um sorry the leaders briefing it was
emailed to members
um uh chair you may be aware that
um you can disarm um a red receipt on
your email so that is not necessarily
indicative of
of whether it's been read or not all
other communications
were sent out um either through the
website uh through social media
um or through a tell me more so there
are different mechanisms for capturing
data for
depending on the medium by which the
information is distributed
um we can tell from tell me more how
many um
[Music]
of those missives were opened and we can
tell
from the traction on social media how
many times our post has been looked at
or shared but that's not the same as
knowing how many times he's actually
been
being read i'm happy to work with com's
officers and pull together
a a short note that explores
some of those options um for a date
chair to be set by you
in relation to uh telephony um the
uh has has been uh it has been explained
to
um mrs cousins mason and and other
colleagues previously
the council is in the process of moving
to a voice over internet
protocol contract which should be in
place in november
to replace the current switchboard as is
set out in the report which is
physically based in the offices and
therefore
does not translate into a virtual
environment so that contract
will be completed in november um
in relation to uh relocation of offices
and
take taking advantage of working from
home to examine
future working patterns um that was
looked at in terms
of connect and the report which went to
executive in july made specific
reference to that point
uh and as um members will see the
uh the asset program has also considered
the uh
impact of uh covert 19 uh in the report
that comes to full council
next week rough sleepers continue to be
dealt with by the council working in
partnership with
um it's with chess as our voluntary
sector partner and across um essex
county council
uh entire administrative area and so
rough sleeping
and prevention of rough sleeping in
connection with
the spread of covert 19 continues to be
top of
that particular priority and funded by
central government
comments in relation to emergency
planning i think we've already picked
those up and
similarly in relation to the hub part of
the local outbreak response plan
is a a mobilization plan for staying the
hub back up
if we ever needed it and certainly the
good relationships that have been
fostered as a result of the of the hub
mean
that the the plans are well in place and
practice and everybody is willing to um
send them back up if required
thank you
thank you angela for those i i know that
some of those um
have been reported in different venues
but i think
they needed to be reported in connection
with this report because they are
obviously
part of arise from this report
the one thing i i can't quite accept
as being um
shall we say acceptable is the issue
with the telephones because
that is ongoing november fine
but so i mean i don't want to go into
the specifics here because i've already
been explained to the
senior management team and they're well
aware of them
but it doesn't appear to have been
resolved and that
some of those things are resolvable
without the equipment
and there's still concerns so
i i still have concerns over that issue
um november is a while away to
for someone to dial it the council and
actually get a response
especially when the receptions aren't
open but
i appreciate that it's difficult thank
you
thank you councillor mrs mason um angela
just in terms of council mrs mason's
point there regarding the
the telephone system um
if the council aware of particular um
constituents that maybe experience those
problems
is there any way the council can be more
proactive in communicating with them
certainly i mean if if there are
individual um
officers who are being um sought
um then um members can always escalate
issues
to the relevant assistant director or
indeed myself
or the managing director residents who
have
any concerns um can email myself or the
managing director if they if they don't
feel that they're necessarily
getting those communications in the
right way
um some of our services are since uh are
now open to bookable face-to-face
appointments
um with members of the public so um that
is now
an option for people particularly who
struggle maybe
with technology thank you
um if i may say that there has been some
improvement so
it's not all doom and gloom and the only
thing that i um would question is the
uh andrew has advised that she's getting
statistics from
tommy moore etcetera but when we've
asked for those in group builders
meetings if not we're forthcoming so
perhaps
we can just discuss that further on
thursday when we have our next meeting
thank you mr chairman okay lovely thank
you very much
um councillor mr hoy yeah can i just uh
quickly uh
state that unfortunately i'm gonna have
to leave the meeting early but i might
be back before the end but unfortunately
i've got to leave
okay okay not a problem thank you for
letting us know
okay sorry about that counselor mr hoy
hey thank you
um chairman um if you just bear with me
as well i'm working off of one computer
tonight rather than two
so i'll be flick flicking and i can't
see what i look like on the screen
so because i've got a pdf in front of me
now
um which is not my normal mode of
working um
okay now lots of thank um
angel hutchins for the report i've i'd i
did start
asking for this to be done back in april
believe it or not in the greek
group leaders meetings not as a way of
blaming anybody but a way of learning as
we go because i think it's very
important that we
find out what works what doesn't work as
we go before it's all forgotten
um especially moving forward
so i see the idea of this as being
constructive to see
what things work what went well and
that's exactly what this is trying to do
however i would disagree with the
chairman if i may
in that sense because of that i don't
think this is too early i think this is
a one of those reports which is forever
being
updated if you follow from very early
because we're always going to be
learning from this
for a very long time and this will also
play into our um emergency planning and
resilience planning of the future
as well um
with regards to the report itself i
would
i think this is possibly what council
wilkinson was talking about as well
i i think i'm not saying the report is
wrong in any way
however i think it emits things which
didn't work
which didn't go too well play into our
emergency planning
and resilience as well i'm not sure
who's got
repeating me i don't find that very good
i'm hearing myself speak again that's
very confusing
it's certainly not on my computer
chancellor's standing as muted again
that's right all right thank you was
that where it was oh yeah right i'll
start again
um so
with regard to the report it says what
we we did well and i don't disagree with
those things
um the hub worked well once it got going
but again that wasn't really our
problem as councillor mason mrs mason
said it
it was being changed all the time but it
was what's being done
so what was done was what was wanted but
it was took a long time
however i don't see that we can really
say that we
did well with waste collection which i'm
not saying we did we did
without saying that leisure didn't work
too well
or saying that the waste collection
worked well
but the bulky waste had to stop for a
little while and it's still not back to
normal yet we still we're still not
doing mattresses although i think that's
going to be
very shortly being done again
so this is the problem they're just a
couple of examples so i think we picked
out what we
what worked and what continued and we've
not really put down what we
what didn't continue and i think
the report isn't going to work until we
recognize what
didn't work because if we don't
recognize what didn't work
how can we put it right in the future
and to say it didn't work isn't
to say we did it badly or we did
something wrong
in the way we were configured at the
time it wasn't possible for it to work
perhaps and this is what i think this
report should be doing it's trying to
identify what didn't work as much as
what did and if we and we're not saying
what didn't work that's the
the first issue um
and then the pdfs are um if i then move
on
we're moving on to i'm not going to
repeat everything else everyone has
said for a change um we have
the lessons learned a bit towards the
back of the report
um
so what went well this is just
a few quotes from people um
the hub went well signage went well in
the
trusted staff was genuine um
i think in many ways this again isn't
really
doing what went well that the refuse
worked well
but why did it work well we're not
really we're saying what went well but
we're not find out why it worked well
and we
and without finding out why they didn't
work well we can't
get that to work in other areas as well
so if we find out why refuse worked well
how can we transfer what went well there
to maybe leisure or bulky waste or
something like that
um that's that point what could have
been done better
um there's there's a lot of thoughts in
this again
but there's not really any conclusions
okay what could have been done
differently
um there's a mention of a lack of detail
here from
members um why haven't we gone back to
members to ask them about the detail i
know i've given detail in
the group leaders calls and i know other
group leaders have as well
i thought i did give some examples in my
feedback that i gave but if i didn't i
apologize and i'm happy to give some
details
of what could have been done differently
um
and then we have the next step steps and
i just like to inquire about paragraph
6.2
we have a covid 19 local outbreak
response plan
it's been put in place and is intended
to operate as a whole council business
continuity plan
um i don't recall
having sight of this has this been sent
to members and i've just missed it
if it hasn't been sent to members can we
have a look at it please i think it
would be
wise for us as members to to see it and
i apologize if we have
been sent here and i've missed it um
that's the
the comments i'm raising it's not again
it's not a criticism of anybody
again i'd like to echo what other people
said about offices i've been they've
they've worked
excellently throughout this period above
and beyond
their calling and i have asked for that
feedback to be fed back to them and i
hope it has
thank you thank you account for mr hoy
um angie did you want to come back
to cancer mr hoy on any of those points
that he's raised or any of the specific
questions that he's asked
i mean particularly he does raise a good
point there about 6.2 where
you do talk about the local outbreak
response plan i have also made a note
just to say
i couldn't remember seeing that and i
was surprised that it didn't form part
of this report
have we both missed it or the members
not got seen that
so chair if i can answer that question
um specifically
because it's an operational delivery
document uh it's not a policy document
so it doesn't need to go through
member governance um the i can
confirm i finished it this morning so um
it is um currently um going to
to the leader and deputy um for um final
sign off and then will be circulated to
to members for information um it's it's
an operational document as i say so
uh and it's intended as as counselor hoy
so eloquently describes intended to be a
continual learning experience
so it will only ever be
as good as the day on which it it's
written
so we will continue to learn from it but
use it as a framework for that
continuous learning
um and in that light really i'd like to
make the comment that this
is the first report i expect of a number
of reports
as you said yourself chair that have
greater and more detail
in relation to um areas of concern or
interest that the
committee wants to pursue in in greater
detail
the information contained in
the feedback is that which was which was
provided to me by um members and
officers
in relation to the request for feedback
so it is entirely limited to to what
people
actually thought when they were asked
that specific question it's not a deep
dive of any particular issues and i
would suggest that that's something that
the
the committee may like to consider um
for for future reports to do that deep
dive exercise in areas
um such as leisure for example where we
know um that that
is likely to come back before uh council
um
before the end of the calendar year um
so it's those sorts of things that i
think are
worth further exploration in the future
but this report was intended to be
a starter for 10. it's intended to pull
together initial
thoughts feelings and feedback um um you
know from the first
four months of the uh of the pandemic as
i've said we'll continue to live with
this for the next 12 to 18 months at
least and so
it's my full expectation that we'll
continue to um
to evolve our learning and to do more
work and more detail and gain greater
feedback as we go
thank you angela um if
i'll just move on and um because i can
see that a few members have indicated to
speak so i do want to
give everybody an opportunity to speak
um councillor gooding
sorry about that chair it was uh stuck
um yes i'd just like to thank angela for
uh
the the report that you've done so far
it is
like you've already said it is a live
document that will be moving forward
so thank you for that and the the
excellent emergency services that
all the officers staff members residents
uh all stepped up to the plate and
worked with the emergency services
for um our vulnerable residents and
i thank you for that that was i believe
was very well
worked i had loads of very good response
from
residents that i spoke to so thank you
for that
um and uh i accept that
you know this is only a starter i'm not
going to repeat what everyone else said
so thank you
thank you thank you councillor goodin
and councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman um i'll try and keep
it brief um
thank you very much as um and just
pointed out this is a starter document
so we just need to
keep that in mind a couple of points um
3.7 the hub
it's great to hear that um everyone's
poised to be stood up again
should it need be um however as a
volunteer myself
um i haven't heard a lot more since um
um we finished um the the recent
operation
um so it would be interesting to see how
those volunteers are being kept engaged
um i would support councillor mason's
suggestion around reviewing the remote
working
of the staff in more detail including
analyzing
the efficiencies that we've made but
also the impact on our staff
how how are our staff how did it affect
their work life balance
so if that could be looked at um
outside of this document i'd also like
to know
um any possible cost savings of course
um
and i think chairman you hit the nail on
the head um
it is for this committee to perhaps um
uh
suggest that we identify and recommend
areas of focus for the next report
thank you chairman
thank you very much councillor mcpherson
um
councillor milne oh yeah thank you
chairman um
yeah i made a note because the report is
um chronological right at the beginning
of the events and then
is more anecdotal later on which is good
in a way but
um if we were logging what went right
and wrong
in relation to
say the contact program what stage it's
at where we're going to be at the end of
all of this
a couple of things that did occur to me
was
through the ict developments
we were already heading towards and had
to discuss the telephone system
and in a normal environment that would
have gone through in the course of
the progress of of our upgrading of i.t
and communications in the contact
program
which is good so i would have liked uh
for the council what
went right wrong a more chronological
approach if we're looking at
a later report so we could say with
respect to
this department this was the main
problem this wasn't fit for purpose and
this is what we're doing and we sort of
split it that way
but obviously
it has been a difficult time with all of
this but what it has shown
is that the moving towards hot desking
and the move to the azure cloud the
improvement of i.t
is actually going the right way because
this will give us resilience if this had
happened in 18 months time i think we
would have a different
picture because there is this
development going on in the organization
so it's a nice thing to add in comments
about that
when we finally get a final report
the other thing is that um
i found that as things progressed and we
improved
our kind of working processes away from
the first few days
in dealing with residents who've got
problems i found the chat
section on the website very useful
people rang back in every case we had a
resolution
of what the problems were and
considering that they're all working at
home and so on that was working
so that learning is has got through
at the moment and and i'm pleased to see
that the uh
the upgrade of the telephone system uh
is being uh
expedited so i want to thank you for
that uh but
that's just the way i would look at it
so when we're looking at the next report
um
it would be fairer as councilwoman
wilkinson has mentioned
if it was done on that approach because
then you're not leaving any stones
unturned as it were
and not missing anything out but uh you
know for an opener it gives us a good
view of what happened and
thank you thank you councilmember
um councillor sparing
thank you thank you chairman um i've
listened to comments
made by respective members few things i
would just like to pick up on though i
mean
uh i think uh angela has made the point
that
you know this is the first of a number
of reports and council ohio was hoping
for one in
in april as you know i think
all members were aware of the pressure
that was on
both officers and everybody
point of order a matter of correcting
the information here
i didn't say i asked for a report to be
presented in april
i said i was asking for the information
to be gathered from
april it's very important point
well i'm sorry michael but the way i
understood it was that you were
anticipating
some sort of report right from the start
and that that was
this should have been ongoing live from
the start sorry if i may
we'd have to agree
the other point i would i would suggest
and i might got this wrong as well then
is you had concerns about the waste
collection
now as far as i'm aware and uh if
uh council on a point of order am i
correct the infection again i said
the waste collection was good i didn't
know you
concerned about the waste collection but
the only one i said was bulky waste i
was using
waste as an example i think you need to
report me correctly
no you you've mentioned that bulk waste
wasn't
still being collected you did indicate
that there were issues with the waste
collection
now i would point out as i was helping
out
sorry cancer mr hoy if you could just
bear with me i will let you come back
if this
some of the issues that were going on
with the waste at the time
was quite simply teams of our waste
collection
were going out of service because one of
this group
was going down with being tested
positive for the virus
so repeatedly we were firefighting
trying to
find groups of employees to come in and
collect the waste
the other point i would just highlight
that members may not be aware of
is that a lot of the when the
furloughing started
and this added to the waste scenario
where we would normally be collecting
waste from
leisure areas i.e parks cherry orchard
we were doing possibly twice a week
we were having to do twice a day and we
would have to restructuring our
operations so i think
by and large and and you know um
we all have learned from this situation
but everybody was placed in a scenario
that they had never dealt with before i
think
officers and members whatever they stood
up
to do what they could to help i don't
think anybody
did things wrong intentionally wrong i
think
things didn't always go according to
plan but sometimes
they were beyond our control as as
you've mentioned about
the hub and then county wanted to take
it over then it was thrown back to us
so i think yes we've learned from it but
i think that
as it was happening you know none of us
had faced this scenario before
nobody did anything wrong intentionally
and though
everybody stood up to try and be counted
i think that's all i've got to say
chairman thank you
thank you councillors very um councillor
mr hoy if you would like to come back i
think
you should have your chance i'm sorry
council sparring i think you totally
misunderstood what i was saying
and um i'm happy to correct the record
for you
i have congratulated the refuse people
on many occasions i've been asked for my
thanks to be passed back through greek
leaders meetings to them doing the hard
work they have done
i raised waste as something that worked
and was rightly
mentioned in this report as working
i've never said it didn't work i said it
worked i said the only issue might have
been bulky waste didn't
couldn't happen for a little while and
it is now back working apart from
mattresses which i know there is a
solution to
but they're still actually not quite
working yet i've at no
point ever said or criticized
the refuse collection okay at
all or in this meeting um and i'd just
like
that to stand please chairman okay
that's fine and i think your comments
you will spend
with regards to um requesting
information april
you i think i'm writing you're you're
now not you're now saying sorry
what you're confirming is that you were
just asking officers to
collate the information back in april is
accurate the clarity on the
group leaders calls for members who
aren't aware the group all group leaders
had a
a phone conference it started off three
times a week and he's now once a week
um regarding the pandemic and other
matters
the and during those calls i said
in april i suggested that it would be a
good point to start collating
information around what's working what's
not working
so we could use it for future reference
thank you chairman
okay thank you councillor mr hoy um
no other members have indicated to speak
at the moment to be honest
i've got lots and lots of questions
scribbled down about the report um
some of which have already been raised
and answered um others
now looking at them seeing a little bit
irrelevant i mean i could
i could ask them but i think there's
that they
appear quite minor now i think in the
general context of
what we've been discussing this evening
um
i think as i started the evening off my
center i would expect this to be
the first of several reports and did
what i'm picking up from this event the
the questions that are coming forward
i think maybe future reports of starting
from the next report
it may be better if it was a report was
set out into
sections possibly and i'm just kind of
put down here some notes for example
technology services finance
communications
which would then give you sections or
some guidance as to
to what we're after does that sound
helpful at all
have any members got any thoughts on
that
chairman i'm very happy to um to to
liaise with you outside of this meeting
and to agree a
template of um subject matter headings
that you would particularly like to
consider
as part of a series of reports going
forward and
the frequency in which those reports
would you'd like them to come forward
thank you thank you jeremy the only
thing i'd add to that is i think
what your summary is exactly how i
understood members um
requests this evening as well so i was
just gonna because there was silence so
i was gonna answer your questions so yes
i agree with you
yeah there was silence i didn't think i
was just waiting but though um yeah so
i'm thinking that everybody's questions
seem to me to fall into
a category um and i think it might just
be
more helpful if we if we focus on
um forming a report which is split into
those categories
um and i think that would help you going
forward as well it's quite a big topic
it as councillor goodin said it's a live
topic that's going to keep changing
um but if if the report continues in
that format
i think it'll be clearer for for members
to actually
look at what's happening and we'll be
able to see as well the progress that
the council is making as well
um councillor mr hoy yeah sorry i think
you probably covered it just in the very
last bit
i don't just to show the progress i
think we and this is what the point i
was trying to make all the way through
we mustn't be afraid to say what didn't
quite work
but i think that's what's like intricate
so i think if we we just
do that what didn't really quite work
doesn't mean it's bad it just means we
didn't quite get it right and i think
there's lots of things lots of
businesses and people didn't get right
and i think it
is quite reasonable that we would have
some of them that was all thank you yes
no i i couldn't agree more um
counseling mr toy and equally i've note
some um
some notes from this evening there are
some real
positive comments and some positive
feedback that have come back
which probably haven't been touched on
enough in the report as well
um you know for example councillor milne
who's just raised a very good point
about the communication about a
particular part of the website that
he found useful and councillor goodin
reporting back in particular about the
feedback that she'd got
and i think it would be useful in that
going forward with regards perhaps under
the heading of communications
not just to highlight those things that
didn't quite work out well but also to
to put in there some good things as well
um and i think
equally perhaps not enough attention on
the positives
has gone into this report which again
isn't a criticism because it is just the
starting point
which is you know i think we've all
accepted we understand
um councillor canel
thank you chair and before i start um
just to
um second all of the the positive
comments around the
reports that's in front of us um
the timely manner in which it's been
brought to us in my opinion and the
commitment to it being the first of uh
a couple or a few um just wanted to
come in uh there's agreement there for
yourself and angela to look at these
headings outside of the call
i'm assuming we can contribute to that
by uh
emailing yourself chair ahead of those
conversations
thank you thank you
council club yes i mean absolutely i
will
obviously speak with andrea um outside
of the meeting
um with regards to i think we do
i can i can understand everybody's
keenness and enthusiasm to get another
report in as soon as possible but
i think we also have to have a a time
break in between each report in order to
kind of let everything catch up as well
but absolutely um all members are
welcome to contact myself or angela
um either or with some suggestions or if
there's some
topics or a category that you feel you
know i haven't
phrased this evening or a particular
point that you want
um included or um an additional
information or data that you want
included then obviously please let
either of us know
um and we will absolutely endeavor to
include as much as we possibly can
um in any future reports um councillor
mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i i agree with
them
the fact that we do need to have some
subjects and i don't think all the
subjects can be dealt with
necessarily at one time i think the
important thing and just to sum up
really what everyone is saying
is that the report needs to be as far as
possible
it needs to be objective if it's
positive
and we know what went happened to make
it positive we can
replicate those learnings if it's
negative
we don't set the negatives we'll never
get improvements
so we what we need is objective
assessments
so that we can look at and learn what
what to do what works well and what
doesn't work
and i think everyone's in agreement with
that but
i would like to echo the comments i
think they've been made before that i
think the whole council
all the members all the staff
and indeed all the residents have
performed and worked very very well in
exceptionally difficult circumstances
and i don't think that should be
acknowledged
on more than one occasion because it's
not often that you see such a
cooperation that we have
um seen in the last five months thank
you mr chairman
thank you yeah i would agree i think
whilst we are here
as a review committee to be a critical
friend it's also important to
to give praise and thanks when we need
to and when we feel it's necessary and i
think quite a few members have
done that um very eloquently and
effectively this evening
so it is on record now that um
we acknowledge what a fantastic job the
council have done
and that we will learn um going forward
so no other members have indicated to
speak on this item
the report the recommendation on the
report
is proposed that we note the content
i move that we do note the content but
just bear in mind members that whilst we
may not all
agree with the content at the moment
this was um
intended to be the first of several and
it was just the starting point
and i think the future reports will be a
bit more specific and i hope that will
um address members concerns
so if if any members um so i'd like to
move that we do
note the contents of that report our
members in agreement if you're not
in agreement would you please raise your
hand
if you are not in agreement
i can't see that any members have raised
their hand so
i'm happy if sonia is to accept that
that's a unanimous decision to note the
content of that report
and obviously members you will see on
the work plan
um probably at the next meeting um once
andrew and i have corresponded
and we've we've got a date that another
report will come forward
um and it it will be fairly soon
chairman if i may just for good measure
i know you moved yeah um
i know you moved the recommendation to
be noted from the chair but can i have a
second second
that's fine sorry i apologize second tip
thank you councilman creation
sorry members okay lovely thank you very
much for that
um obviously everybody's welcome to stay
for the next item
um if you don't need to stay which is
mainly aimed at
officers or or guests then you're more
than welcome to leave this
meeting now and if you do then thank you
for joining us
um item number number seven sorry is the
review committee's annual report
again this report's been circulated to
members
um it's a fairly self-explanatory report
it's an annual report that we do
each year and it has generally
followed the same sort of format now
i am recommending that we move the
report um
and recommend that to full council
however i would just like to
ask members whether or not they've got
any objections i have very loosely
discussed this with
um sonya and
at the next when the next report
is presented i would like to possibly
look at
making some changes to the report um
and i just want some members thoughts on
that and that would just include
us investigating what other councils are
putting in their annual reports
whether there's things that we are
excluding from reports not intentionally
but that would make the report more
informative for members of the public
in it i would also like to put in there
for myself and for future chairman of
review
um the opportunity to make a statement
um just about how they felt the year
went
um and if any members have any comments
on that if they think it's a good idea a
bad idea then let me know
um councillor mrs mason
yeah thank you mr chair i'm going to
slightly
veer off of the actual report
i know sorry
can you hear me yes if i can
yeah um i don't know if other members
have read this but we we had an email
through from the center for
for public scrutiny and i think it's
just
worth while if i just read a few
comments out from that because it
it appertains to the own view and
scrutiny guidance
and i think it's helpful especially in
the light of the
um reports that
and it says basically this is about the
whole council
a commitment has to begin with the chief
council's chief executive and political
leadership
a meaningful committed commitment
accompanied by action not just words
a cultural commitment to scrutiny is
about taking action to encourage
scrutiny
that is challenging uncomfortable and
potentially politically difficult
scrutiny's part in this bargain is
to recognize that its work must be
designed to have an impact
and it carries on along those lines it
says the world must be focused
and carefully prioritized
and i understand what you're saying and
i understand your report
but it also says that it the the right
of people have to be selected on the
committee to hold the
um position of chair recognise the
political element of chair selection
it's a very interesting report and
what you're saying about the future i
wonder if this would be helpful for
if members haven't read it to read it
because it is
um talks about gathering evidence and
making recommendations
[Music]
um as i said not technically on the
subject of your report but appertaining
to it
thank you thank you council mrs mason
i do think you're right and i think it
would be a good idea for for members to
have
a look at that um and perhaps with my
comments earlier you
members may um get a better
understanding of
what it is um i'm kind of proposing
um i whilst i've i'm not taking anything
away from the content of this report and
the reports before it
i do think it's been a while um since
these reports have been looked at and i
do think they
could be improved upon and that's what
hopefully
i would like to be able to to bring
before the review for the next report
um counselor mr hoy
thank you chairman sure i was hunting
for my mute button there um
yeah i i would support you in um
changing the report to the report style
and perhaps what it reports as well
um and i'm happy for that to go ahead
um i just want to draw attention to a
few points which possibly back up what
you're talking about but certainly back
up what i'm talking about
um and it's it's how things are reported
in this report
and it it's possibly
something which i was alluding to in the
previous um item as well in some ways
so item five we have about ict review
and it just says following the terms
initial report to the committee in june
2019
the team met with officers several times
to monitor the migration of the council
servers and associated costs
to completion um it doesn't really say
anything does it
i don't know what's happening just by
reading that
remember the public wouldn't really know
what's happening it's not really giving
indication
if if they're on target not on target
what what are the targets even and how
them
how how is the migration going it just
doesn't say anything on that
for instance that's one item carbon
neutrality as well
um 10.3 so that's paragraph 2.3
it just says at the september 2019
meeting it was agreed that a working
group would be formed
um an update was received at the dry
2020 meeting
um it doesn't really say that the report
went
what did you say what was discussed no
it was discussed and
it went to the couch and the council
agreed i think that it's not
giving them anything positive about it i
know i
abstained on it but still it should say
what happened to it i think that's an
example
and this runs through the report um
it doesn't give 10.5 there's been one
this is around the um
oh what one is it it's the um grass
cutting or the um
management company report this one i
believe publicly yep
there's been a meeting so why doesn't it
say there's been one meeting and again
this goes back to the whole report
doesn't mention covert at all but has
been delayed future meetings have been
delayed by kovid it could say that
so people understood why there's not
been another meeting um
10.6 i think i want to suggest an
alteration to this if i may
if i read this for members and if a
member would like to
without looking up i'll hasten to add
can they tell me what this is about
at the december 2019 meeting the
committee
considered details of the private
members bill which had been considered
by the last parliament the committee
noted the bill had not progressed beyond
its first reading of the house of
commons
i couldn't remember what that was about
there might be some members here with
the
memory of me um i think we really need
to say that it was
i looked i did look this up by the way i
didn't know and it was the local
electricity bill that's right
otherwise no one knows what it's about
um
and then one of our favorite ones one of
my favorite ones
um is probably paragraph
10.7 which is something we've also been
speaking about tonight which is
a paragraph regarding emergency planning
that was quite an interesting meeting i
felt i think there were a lot of points
being put
forward during that discussion um
and a lot of points for rise that
members were unhappy about emergency
planning
um i think it might it would benefit the
council to know that the review
committee were unhappy about emergency
planning
and at the final paragraph it was
requested an updated report be presented
at the april 2020 meeting
regarding training for members who may
be contacted out of ours
that's not what it was decided
it wasn't just training um
so i'm not sure where that came from um
it was
lots of things beyond that and i've lost
the report for that one i think i've
just deleted it
um i mean i think it was
of training volunteers information about
around communication protocol
and how it can be relaunched to members
confirmation that the emergency number
is more prominently placed on the
council website
a testing regime for tendering out of
house emergency services
and the result of this testing and also
the fact that this has been requested
for
three years running i think council
embassy mcpherson raised that
so i think that's a specific example and
i think
this is where the report fails us in
that it
it it's very bland doesn't say very much
and doesn't say
the good things that we think we've done
all the
things which we still need to work on
which goes back to what actually
councilman mrs
mason has just said in in that very good
report received
i'll leave it there but i really can i
just propose that we do change
um paragraph 10.6 so it refers to the
local electricity
bill okay um
thank you councilman and uh largely i
i couldn't agree more and i think that's
the conversation that
i've had with sonia
i do appreciate that with regards to
this particular
report perhaps the person that
put the report together um wasn't as
experienced
as um paul gowers who is obviously no
longer with us
but what along with the authority sorry
i need to rephrase that um
and i and i would like that to be just
born in mind by members
but i do agree with you counselling mr
hoyer i think that there are
a few items or a few points in this
report which are
too brief and don't give enough and my
main concern is that
this document is a publicly available
document and i think if you're a member
of the public looking at that to get a
better idea of exactly what we do
um you may struggle and
i think it does need change it does need
updating
and and hopefully that is what we will
work towards
and again as per the other item um and
what council of canal wrote
if any members have got any idea or want
to put any ideas or
or want any input in how they would like
to see the report put together or if
there's any uh
anything they've seen other councils do
that we're not doing in that report
then let me know please or let some of
you know because i will lose you i'll
sign you on this
um councillor sorry jim can i come
back um
i know i've mentioned about the the um
10.6 can't is that agreed that we can
add about the local electricity to that
paragraph
um yeah i absolutely i'm absolutely
happy to agree with that that's
and if ever the members are as well it
was it was quite a brief discussion
actually
the review committee but i do think it
is important that that is specified
so that if anybody does look at that
they can know exactly what it is we were
talking about so i'm happy for that to
be
to be included and i don't know if it is
possible
for for i'm happy to
for it to be delegated to the chairman
of the cap chairman of the review
committee but if it could be fleshed out
a little bit more in some places
such as yeah i mean quite simply
this went to full council and was agreed
or something that simple
yep absolutely no that's not a problem
i'll i'll do that
so i've got a bit of a delay i think
thank you sorry i'm
i'm muted again that's another i think
is that mine uh councillor milne
uh yeah um that's just a suggestion
really if we're reviewing the
way we do the annual report it has to be
a roundup
of the year so yeah you can't drill down
too much but of course
it's a modern document and it's in a
modern format so
we could put appropriate evidence in
either an appendix or hyperlink it
so when we get the electricity bill
somebody said what knows that
we can put links in so they can go and
look at it but when we're actually
considering it
in the council um we've got
a sort of tracy of the year's work um
and appropriate evidence can be put in
it so we don't have to put the entire
document or anything pnc
and we do have lots of really good
material
um just it would would make it
a more a more modern document so i'm all
for that
and it really answers
questions to the readers isn't it if
anyone's got questions about anything
there
so we we can have the detail but it's a
vehicle for delivering it
sort of thing so we can also have the
the pricey as it were of the year so
that's
what i would suggest is just just my
view anyway
thank you very much um councilman the
idea
yes is to to modernize it slightly but
try and get that balance between
keeping it as a an overall summary
which you know by the the very meaning
is not to have a lengthy document but
also to try and put a bit more substance
in there
which i think is possibly lacking a
little at the minute
councilor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman um i think i agree
with the
generally with the comments that being
made and i accept that
the document's quite antiquated and it
needs change
but for now we need to deal with the
report that we have and that we're
dealing with now
and i do agree that it needs fleshing
out it's
it is not a report at the moment it's
not even a summary
it needs some fleshing out before it's
acceptable
um as a draft report it's it's fine but
i mean even if you just take the very
last sentence during the year one
decision has not been subject to calling
what decision when
that that that isn't that sort of
fleshing out is factual
and very brief and it should be done
what i would
suggest and i'd like to propose this mr
chairman if you're acceptable that
um members that have concerns like uh
councillor hoy and
anyone else um gives the concerns to you
and that um
you arrange the fleshing out
and to save time because presumably you
want to present this
but once you've fleshed it out you just
email it to everyone and then if there's
any
concerns then they can be addressed
unless you're prepared to wait until the
next meeting but
as the document is the document i don't
think is
um in a finished state
so i'd like to propose that it is
fleshed out as council hoy has said that
you know there's some general comments
on there but they need to be
slightly more specific um they need to
have facts on them they need to
not necessarily have dates but certainly
an indication of
the subject would help
and if you're happy as chair i'm sure
you will be
to to arrange the fleshing out and to
make sure that all members of the
committee are
happy with that i'm sure you'll be happy
to do that outside of committee
otherwise it should come back to the
committee
thank you thank you council mrs mason
um yeah i mean i'm happy with that i
think there was a slight concern about
the time
um that it had taken to produce the
report and a lot of that
unfortunately is to do with
um issues outside of the review
committee maybe some personnel issues
but i am more than happy to look at this
i mean like you say
cancer mrs mason as a draft report um
yes it's there and it but it does need a
little bit of tidying up and i think
i would tend to agree with you and i
think um i'm happy to work with anybody
if there's any particular points
obviously i've noted the ones that have
been raised this evening at the meeting
if there are any other items in that
report that um
any member wants to raise with me then
that's absolutely fine please raise it
with me
um and i'm more than happy for that to
be emailed
two members and for agreement
councillor hookway
thank you chairman um yes
when when is this report
likely to be presented to full council
for approval
um good question i would like to present
it to full council as soon as possible
but i do appreciate that if if members
would like me to
um type it up and and make it a bit more
informative
which i'm happy to do um
uh i'll have is it i'll have to talk to
to discuss this with sonia if that's
okay
members um but it will be presented to
full council as soon as possible within
the next
definitely within the next two full
council meetings if not the next one
i will aim to try and get at the next
one i've only got one screen as well and
i'm trying to
look to see when the next full cancel is
apologies
it's the 20th of october chairman
ah then i would anticipate presenting it
at the 20th of october yeah i don't
think we would need more time than that
but if members are happy with counseling
mrs mason's suggestion which i am
happy with myself um then that that will
be the plan that i will
take feedback from you we will try and
tidy this report up
i will email it out to members for
comments and agreement
with a review to report it or present it
at the 20th october meeting
our members happy with that
that's my proposal do i need to do i
need a second
i think i do i'll second that
thank you very much and if members are
in agreement with that
fantastic if sorry if members are not in
agreement with that can you please raise
your hand
by the icon
the raised hand icon if you i'm not
happy with that
no one's raised a hand so i'll accept
that that members are in agreement with
that
and i thank you very much
um moving on to
iso number eight which is the key
decisions document
um hopefully members have seen a copy of
that
um there are three items on the key
decision document
um if any members have got any rather
than me go through each individual
item that is shown on the key decision
document have any members got
any comments or questions regarding any
of those
key decisions that that are shown out to
three
it doesn't appear that any members do so
i i assume that members are
oh sorry no counseling i couldn't find
my mute button again i'm afraid
um it was only a quick one around um
page 3 6 20 which is the environmental
health service plan
um is this
i'm just a bit i haven't had a chance to
check previous reports but i thought
this was due to be done earlier
but i know this is regarded as quite a
high risk area
so i just wonder if you could get
information on how
this is progressing if we haven't
got a suitable plan in place at the
moment or an updated plan
okay thank you um sonia can i just ask
your comments on with regards to that
well it's
as you can see from the key decisions
document it's um
it's it stands for decision to be made
on that
in september um if members want a more
specific timeline i will have to update
you outside
the meeting which i i can email members
outside to uh to give an update
okay i think by the sound of it captain
mr you would prefer that
yeah i'm happy with that i know it's
just this does come from an audit
committee is a quite a risky area um as
well on the audit committee
so i think it's con from our point of
view on review it's something we should
also keep an eye on
thank you okay so sonia would you be
happy to do that for us and
report back yes i'll
report to members outside the meeting on
that okay
thank you very much um councillor mrs
mason
uh thank you mr chairman i haven't
normally we would have the work plan on
the
agenda and it's not i wonder if that was
deliberate or an oversight
um because i do have a question under
that topic if you'll allow me to put it
in or would you
prefer it to another meeting
uh no i was planning to discuss the work
plan today i think originally it was
missed off the agenda
um sonia i thought that the agenda had
been revised and
sent round is that not correct showing
the inclusion of the work plan
no the the agenda hasn't been revised
right okay have members received the
work plan sonia
no no
okay but um
but um if i may the
the area that i was concerned with is
one that i was chairing which was the
um looking into the management companies
the meeting we had was six months
yeah sorry just one second are you
referring to the work plan
yes okay i will come back to you in just
one second
it's just going back to the key decision
document yes sorry
um obviously there was a query on um the
third key decision which sonia is going
to look in to for us
and report back so other than that are
other members members happy
um with the key decision document and
for somebody to come back
if there are any objections if anyone
has any question can you press the raise
hand icon
i don't think there's going to be i
think that was that was dealt with
and as nobody has raised their hand
um we'll take that as acceptable and
we'll move on now to the next item which
is the work plan
um members i do apologize originally the
work plan was missed off the agenda and
i did raise this
um it was an error it absolutely wasn't
intentional
um and i hadn't realized that members
hadn't received a copy of the work plan
um counselor mrs mason
if if i can come back to you and you can
raise your point and then i'll discuss
with sonia
how we may progress this but if you
could if you would like to
to continue apologies for interrupting
that the
the open spaces uh the question of
management companies on
new build sites the um
offices were researching information now
i appreciate we've had a very
uh busy time i believe that the officer
that was
um fundamentally researching it is not
at work at present but i
think it's too much of an important
situation to be left
for longer it's been nine months
so if that officer is not available then
we do need
to have appropriate uh resources
so that that committee can continue
um council mrs mason can i just check
with you um
did the committee meet i do yes
recall it when's the last time they met
just out of interest
december i believe i believe it was
december
but it was said yeah we haven't met
since uh march anyway
uh midfield
which is understandable in the
circumstances however
and yeah that is not something that
could be pushed to decide
i i don't think it should be left any
longer
thank you for drawing that to my
attention um i'll discuss with sonia
regarding
office of resources on that item i do
recall it and i do agree with counseling
mrs mason i think it is important that
we revisit it
um sorry can i take some advice as
members haven't received a copy of the
work plan
i have got a copy of it um
would it be prudent i mean for me to
mention that
we did discuss the work plan at the last
review committee meeting
we discussed various items that weren't
shown at the time and sonia has
updated the work plan and included those
items
where we agreed they would fit at the
moment
um sonic i think it might be better
i'll be able to circulate a copy of the
work plan
um obviously first thing tomorrow two
members
just for them to give them the
opportunity to look at it i don't think
there'll be many questions regarding
because i think
generally overall it does now represent
what we discussed at the last meeting
but certainly if any members have got an
issue with the work plan
they can come back to me for yourselves
on your um
tomorrow or thereafter
that that's absolutely fine i'm uh i can
email
that out to members tomorrow and
and you know and obviously we can we can
deal with any queries and issues that
they might have from
uh but you know remotely
okay thank you sonia and just to let
members know that obviously
the work plan has been updated by
someone who is um
still still learning the role which was
why there was a little bit of an error
in the first place within missing but
um i do apologize for that counseling
assist counselor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman i'm sure we accept
that
you know it's a complex situation and
members of staff have to have learning
and errors are accepted
and there's no need to apologize that
happens
but to make matters easier in
the future we have standard agendas
for the review committee which
um including the whipping declarations
perhaps the key
decisions document perhaps the work plan
could be there in the template so it's
not lost in the future
because it is an important part of our
consideration
thank you thank you no i completely
agree and i'm not quite sure
if i'm honest why it was missed in the
first place because i
my belief was that it would have been
you a template would have been used but
um it it was revised and i received a
copy of it but perhaps
i didn't realize that that copy hadn't
been circulated to members so
um i do apologize for oversight that's
perhaps something i should have picked
up on
um but as we've discussed sonia will
send that
um work plan round um first thing in the
morning
and any anything on that work hand any
members of any questions please let us
know
um i don't think there will be too many
questions because as i've said
it does now reflect um what we discussed
at the last meeting so
so hopefully members will be unsatisfied
when they do when they see it but
obviously any questions please let me
know
um it doesn't look like anybody else has
any questions so
on that note um we'll close the meeting
we'll finish the meeting um thank you
everybody for for coming this evening
and for attending
um keep safe and hopefully we'll see
each other all soon thank you ever so
much yeah
thank you goodnight everybody